bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fan i j
oggi siamo qui in un nuovo blog non ho
mai fatto blog in vita mia mai e ne ho
fatti due nell'arco di cinque giorni
praticamente è un miracolo
comunque volevo iniziare dicendovi che
questo video a differenza di tutti
quanti i miei video normali
cercherò di non fare neanche un taglio
perché diciamo questo blog non è un
video per intrattenere ma più che altro
per informarvi su delle cose che sono
molto importanti che accadrà nei
prossimi giorni ho tagliato o sbagliato
mi sono inceppato pazienza raga non ce
la faccio
vabbè comunque da adesso in avanti
jaqueline a farne più
comunque volevo ringraziarvi veramente
tantissimo per i 25mila iscritti ragazzi
un traguardo incredibile non ho parole
veramente c e 20 c 20 c 25 mila o mio
dio veramente ragazze
no io non ho ogni volta che che succede
una cosa del genere per i diecimila
iscritti per i 15.000 dico sempre che
non ho parole ma ma perché è vero c'è io
non so descrivervi veramente la mia
gioia raga 25.000 sono tantissimi cioè
che poi appena uscito il video le 25.000
oggi che praticamente il giorno dopo
siamo a 26
serve una cosa assurda vi voglio
veramente ringraziare con tutto il cuore
perché 25mila iscritti sono un traguardo
che non mi sarei mai aspettato ma
soprattutto non mi sarei mai aspettato
così presto
c'è offerto il canaio praticamente video
di 15.000 l'ho fatto a pasqua che era
tipo due settimane fa e siamo a 25.000
10.000 iscritti due settimane ma cos'è
non so non so cosa dire raga veramente
in grazie grazie infinite
ok raga dopo i ringraziamenti dire che
possiamo venire alle cose diciamo più
interessanti per chi aspetta come se
fosse l'ultimo giorno della sua vita il
mio harlem 6 che la sfida del ciapi
bagni diciamo che questo è il tema
principale del blog perché oggi proprio
oggi mentre state vedendo il video io
sono dovrei essere arrivato a praga in
questo momento io sono a pagamento
mentre state vedendo il video perché vi
avevo già annunciato in precedenza che
il 14 e il 15 di aprile il 16 di aprile
alla terza lo azzeccato
ho dovuto guardare in basso perché ce
l'ha data del computer va beh il 16 di
aprile io sono partito appunto oggi per
praga per una gita scolastica appunto
quindi raga per quattro giorni non
vedrete video nuovi perché non potrò
caricarli però tranquilli che appena
ritorno si parte in quarta adesso vi
spiego meglio che cosa intendo comunque
se comunque sentite diciamo nostalgia o
robe del genere cioè le playlist lo
fatte nel senso che io quando metto
video al giorno sempre le playlist
quindi nel caso ve ne siate perso
qualcuno
potete vederlo nel caso comunque se
volete rivedervi video vecchi le
playlist sono fatte apposta quindi
spero che possiate sentire di meno la
mia mancanza grazie a questo comunque
adesso arriviamo alle news ancora più
importanti ovvero le nuove serie ma
prima volevo parlarvi del fatto che il
giorno era sabato il 14 il 14 di aprile
sono stato a torino comics come vi avevo
annunciato ho incontrato moltissimi di
voi non mi sarei mai aspettato una cosa
del genere cioè sarete stati in una
trentina senza esagerare c'è una cosa
veramente assurda e voglio veramente
ringraziarvi perché siete c'è è stato un
delirio io allora praticamente ho fatto
i biglietti come ha messo il piede
dentro
avevo ancora una gamba fuori come sulla
gamba dentro favi ecco tifavi fare oh
mio dio è stata una cosa assurda si
eravate tipo davanti all'entrata eravate
circa sei o sette ne sono mi ricordo che
mi aspettava che tutti insieme dopo aver
fatto le foto praticante mi hanno
fermato e mi hanno detto fa viti abbiamo
fatto un regalo e io ci sono rimasto
tipo un po incredulo come direi
addirittura cioè non me l'aspettavo è
praticamente mi hanno dato questa busta
qui e all'interno trovato il regalo
giudicate voi
[Musica]
c'era ga il pupazzetto di cat mario mio
zio draga guardate chiaro e stupendo
cioè uguale è veramente perché poi è
stato fatto a mano c'è veramente
fantastico
nonostante io oggi il soggetto del
regalo vi ringrazio veramente tantissimo
perché è stato veramente un bellissimo
pensiero
e poi veramente guardate che roba è
uguale e tra l'altro stava anche
pensando che prima o poi dovrò fare
dietro alle mie spalle tipo una mensola
un qualcosa dove metterò tutti i regali
diciamo che mi avete fatto perché già
iniziano a esserci tra la nutella
questo lo slider man che se vedete in
alto a destra che fa bay gestacci e
vabbè comunque a parte dovrò anche
cambiare poste perché quello là lo
detesto che ce lo da secoli
adesso l'antistress con cui cacciarmi
quando gioca hackett mario l'ultima cosa
prima di passare alle serie per quanto
riguarda le foto che abbiamo fatto
perché abbiamo fatto un miliardo di foto
allora raga praticamente vi spiego un po
la situazione io al torino comics
ci sono andato che aveva una faccia da
morto per arrivare lì mi sono alzato
tipo alle 7 alle 8 di domenica comunque
quindi giorni qui potrei dormire però
sono andato a dormire nonostante mi sia
alzato le otto sono andato a dormire
tardissimo molto oltre la mezzanotte
perché dovevo praticamente evitare il
video dei 25mila iscritti ovviamente
sono andato a dormire non ho dormito
nulla è la mattina mi son dovuto alzare
per andare al torino comics quindi
ragazza ero arrivato lì che ci avevo due
occhiaie da panda avevo talmente una
faccia da sommato che al momento di fare
il biglietto alla biglietteria che i
cosplay pagano di meno il biglietto
volevano farmelo pagare di meno perché
mi avevano preso per un cosplay degli
zombie di residenti vol più a parte
questo è diciamo che la stragrande
maggioranza delle foto c'è una faccia
tipo così quindi diciamo che avevo detto
che avrei fatto l'album per le foto dei
comics fa ha detto che soltanto cinque o
sei foto su 30 alle quali sono si
salvano preferisco non farlo comunque va
beh vi ringrazio a tutti quanti per
essere stati così gentili e fantastici
allora ragazzi devo iniziare delle serie
nuove appena inizierà fra galilei
incominciò
la prima in assoluto è quella che vi
avevo promesso alla fine di giugno
ovvero la serie horror che dovevo
iniziare dopo john quella che sarebbe
dovuto andare a sostituire john che non
ho ancora inizi che ancora non ho
iniziato scusatemi è la inizierò al più
presto state tranquilli poi dopo di
questo appunto cat mario 2 che amia
disgrazia anche a causa di questo lo
devo continuare così almeno diciamola
tiste quindi anche quello continuerà
dopodiché penombra allora ragazzi non
sto più facendo penombra per il semplice
fatto che appena ho tempo in mente di
fare l'episodio da un'ora fino a
concluderlo tutto quanto quindi ragal
prossimi episodi di penombra sarà
lunghissimo ma sarà quello conclusivo
cioè nel senso fare una puntata
lunghissima fino alla fine anche quello
stessa cosa vale anche per scriverle nel
senso che anche di scribblenauts è in
mente di fare un episodio lunghissimo
che ha ri lunghissimo non so quanto può
essere lungo ma comunque che arrivi fino
alla fine è così quelle due serie si
concluderanno al più presto
quindi se rimuove la nuova serie horror
dopo di che devo iniziare una serie che
mi avete consigliato veramente in tanti
che non è proprio un gioco di preciso ma
praticamente mi avete volete che io
faccia tipo un gioco come a honey bee
c'è uno dei rocket man un gioco tipo del
genere comunque giochi degenerò loro
raga io ne approfitto per chiedervi se
avete un videogame in particolare che
volete che io faccia di questo genere
tipo i boney eccetera
consigliate melo qui nei commenti
appunto su facebook no anzi nei commenti
qui sotto il video meglio ecco quando
rientrerò inizierò anche con gli inviò
rumor che è da un po che non li faccio
quindi tranquilli
credo di avervi detto tutto non mi sono
segnato pro tutto quanto si non mi pare
ci sia qualcos'altro voglio ringraziarvi
nuovamente per il traguardo dei 25 mila
iscritti
aspettatevi l'harlem 6 chiuderci aviv
anni prima possibile appena torno però
appena possibile l'inizio di sicuro
questo sabato dovrebbe uscire un video
tranquillamente quindi ragazzi o vi
saluto
ci vediamo tra quattro giorni appena
torno appunto da praga
non so con quale coraggio io andrò a
fare l'harlem sheikh ma vabbè comunque
mio ritorno avrete tutto quanto è nel
caso abbiate appunto nostalgia
ricordatevi ci sono le playlist tutto
quanto
quindi nel caso consolatevi con quelli
quindi raga noi ci vediamo sabato 6
video vi è piaciuto come al solito
lasciato commento mi piace anche alla
pagina di facebook come non li video
trovate nella descrizione se non siete
ancora iscritti iscrivetevi io è che
mario vi salutiamo e noi ci rivediamo il
20 aprile bella ragazzi